direction de loi ou la mobilisation des
salariés de thé kalemie taïro spasmes ne
prend des airs de marathon cela va faire
trois semaines maintenant qu'ils
manifestent devant leur entreprise
une cinquantaine de grévistes occupent
l'entrée livraison jour et nuit à tour
de rôle pour bloquer l'entrée et la
sortie des véhicules en cause la
fermeture programmée du site pour une
partie d'entre eux pas de licenciements
mais une délocalisation à 100 km de là
l'usso dans la sarthe
la question des primes supra légales du
plan social est par ailleurs un sujet de
discorde avec la direction on s'appelle
collomb on a un petit réchaud apprendra
le feu on a une couette charmant quand
même de contenir
ils sont une cinquantaine de grévistes
la moitié des salariés du site cela fera
trois semaines après demain qui campe 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
la circulation des voitures et des
camions est bloqué ici seuls les piétons
peuvent passer en juin dernier la
direction leur annonce la fermeture de
l'usiné et leur propose d'aller
travailler à l'usso à une centaine de
kilomètres de là hors de question pour
la plupart pourquoi j'irai à lui se
refaire une vie j'ai un crédit ici j'ai
une maison pour l'instant parce que ma
famille qui est implanté ici à nos amis
également et on ne va pas changer de vie
pour le moment on a un homme maisons nos
enfants qui sont cons leur petit réseau
de copains également le plan social
comprend des contreparties pour les
salariés volontaires
donc pour ceux qui partent à du soya pas
de problème on a tous on à la navette
pour 18 mois où on allait une prime de
150 euros avec le maintien de salaire
par contre pour ceux ci s'en aille à
rien et ils veulent pas lâcher quoi la
direction propose 2 1 à 6 mois de
salaire soit environ 5000 euros par
exemple pour yoann pirou et ses quatre
ans d'ancienneté
les grévistes demandent un congé de
reclassement ainsi qu'une prime
supra-légale plus conséquente la suite
pour eux dans l'espoir de se faire
entendre
aller manifester devant les clients de
tekka limite des grands groupes comme
ariane airbus boeing ou safran